[موسيقى]
حضرت من الصباح الباكر من الساعه السادسه
فجرا لان المحكمه كانت قد حددت على الموعد
الساعه 11:00
ضلينا موجودين في الساحه تقريبا لقرابه
الساعه ثلاثه ونصف او اكثر يعني معناش
ساعات نحدد بس تقريبا في هذا الحدد بعد
ذلك
تم استدعاءنا لدخول لقاءة المحكمه كلمتين
اللي صارت داخل القاعه انه تم تاجيل يعني
الموضوع الاستئناف ليوم الاحد وانه صعب
الاتصال عملوا زي مسرحيه او تمثيليه انه
صعب الاتصال في الانترنت
بالرمله وانه صعب ننقل اي صوره من داخل
الرمله وانسحب القاضي واحنا يعني داخل
القاعه طلبوا منا الخروج من القاعه
[موسيقى]
كانت معامله قاسيه جدا اصروا كل الاصرار
على انه ليس لك حق تشوفي زوجك انت معكيش
تصريح بالتالي هسا مرفوضه انك تفوتي تزوري
حتى لو طلع لك تصريح المحكمه هون ممنوع
تيجي عليها مره ثانيه نحط عليك رفض امني
ممنوع تفوتي اي محكمه بعد انت عملتيه
والاعتصام اللي سويتيه داخل قاعه المحكمه
انا بقول لهم لو بطلع بايدي بعمل اكثر من
هيك لاتمكن اني اعرف اي معلومه عن زوجي
ولو كان بايدي وما يشحطونيش من داخل قاعه
المحكمه لحد هون كان عملت اكثر من هيك لكن
يعني اكثر من ذلك لكن من بيدهم الامر ومن
يملكون الامر الاصل ان يتحركوا بسرعه قبل
فوائد الارانب
من الزياره الصليب الاحمر مش عارفه من
زياره بضال لحقوق الانسان مش عارفين امنوا
ان الزياره فبالتالي احنا صرنا بنعتمد بس
نيجي على المحكمه مشان نشوفه اما اذا بدكم
اخرى تمنعونا من شوفه في داخل المحكمه لا
احنا بنوصل رساله لكل العالم ان هاي
المسرحيه اللي جوا هي لا تنطلي على الشعب
الفلسطيني ولا تنطلي على احرار العالم ان
هناك يعني عداله وهناك محاكم وهناك تنسيق
وهناك كان حرص على حياه الشخص هم بعيدين
كل البعد عن الاهتمام بحياه الشيخ خضر او
الحفاظ على سلامته
احنا في مرحله خطر شديد احنا خايفين جدا
على الشيخ احنا متوقعين باي لحظه ممكن
يجينا خبر استشهاده احنا بنحكي عن اثنين
وثمانين يوم اضراب عن الطعام متواصل موجود
في ظروف اعتقال صعبه لا يتناول الى الماء
يعني الشيخ لما كان قبل سبعه ايام تعرض
للاغماء اربع مرات خلال لقاعه المحكمه كيف
هسه صار وضعه فبالتالي التعويل علينا يوم
الاحد او انه اخرجوا في محكمه ليوم الاحد
وراح تشوفيه يوم الاحد هي عباره عن تاويل
ونسال الله عز وجل السلامه للشيخ وان الله
سبحانه وتعالى ينصره انا